bonjour maïté aujourd'hui ce camp pour
une fois je vais pas vous demander ce
qu'on va faire parce que je le vois on
va faire du foie gras du foie gras est
un foie gras un peu spécial comme on n'a
jamais fait encore c'est un foie gras un
jeune et au champagne
alors ça c'est pour un repas de fête oui
un repas de fête où il va nous falloir
plein de bonnes choses je vois aussi les
rognons va faire également des rognons
je les vois rien de vaut au champagne
aussi les rognons c'est l'entrée le x 9
x ont laissé leur gré et les rognons ce
sera le plat oui lui vend pas il vaut
quoi pour tous à ébène ou photoshop a
évidemment il est là et puis la fille de
champagne aussi et nous faut faire la
gelée et parce qu'on ne sait pas si le
circuit en haïti quelqu'un ça n'a rien à
voir vous achetez la gelée les très
belles et très clair les jolis mais ça
n'a rien à voir la jolie que vous allez
faire vous même et si j'achète le paquet
tout près avec les normes énorme énorme
et dans l'eau on va les laisser pour ce
faire le pas de ça nous on se fait une
autre jeu des anneaux comme chez maman
comme ses grandes mains quant à
l'arrière au nom des parents me faisais
c'est très facile les caisses qu'il faut
l'aimer il faut d or d auzat moelle des
os dans la dépense othello de vaud voilà
il faut un bon saut de jarret vous
pouvez faire avec des hausses de vos
pareils aussi si on n'a pas les moyens
de se payer à manger halal aux arrêts et
le bruit de boeuf pareil pour celles du
gicl a le mérite à la noix brouillard le
vent peuvent faire ça je comprends pas
pourquoi bon ça c'est ce qui est le plus
important c'est le prix de beaux et les
puits de vos écrits gélatineux et il en
faut pour faire la gélatine et bien
entendu autrement dit c'est comme un
bouillon auquel on ajoute ceux pied pour
donner du corps il pourrait reprendre
exactement vous faire preuve la rend si
vous êtes à terre libre et il faut de
les chanter de l'oignon il faut du temps
des taux de girofle des carottes du
persil du poireau et nous faut aussi
entre
quan de devancer de la gelée aussi assez
sa voix importante pour que ça prenne
voilà une autre fois bien évidemment il
a ma série combien de temps il a macéré
24 heures quand même est sale et marif
saler poivrer et on a misé en champagne
très bien là et bien pour commencer dans
un certain génie urbain pour l'europe et
de vaud et qu'est ce qu'on a fait dans
l'eau bouillante que j'ai mis à mourir
pour l'occasion avait mis du sel et du
poivre dans la gorge à m non après s'en
suit alors les os toute la vie en orbite
outils mais très bien jouer les passe
très bien
tous timbaland ou à moelle savall mangou
est logique juste ça c'est bon non nous
on ne mangera et celui-là le jarret fut
jean simmons cameron le stroma s'arrêter
expérience aussi les petits légumes la
couenne la couenne d'abord la couenne on
aurait pu la poupée quand les parades et
renouer rien à peu tranquille on la
condamnerait non non non non c'est
jamais trop petit ne leur donnera
meilleur goût mais ça c'est notre
oignons avec les coûts de girofle ça
c'est ça qu'est pas ce que vont parfaire
un très bon goût là on a mis poireaux et
carottes et il envoie beaucoup mais
c'est bon là et ensuite on a installé un
probable de laurier un petit peu voilà
une branche un petit peu de serre pour
les dujardin sa part pub bierne
saler poivrer
vous savez il faut relever pour du sel
et voir et on va fermer on va dire quoi
rien dr aux six heures minimum six
heures et à au moins six heures de temps
autrement dit si on veut faire un foie
gras en gelée il faut faire l'âge légal
à la veille et la coulée la filtrer
après on verra
voilà on verra tout à l'heure non
maintenant il faut qu'on s'occupe du
pointeur du foie gras il a macéré 24
heures oui ça l'est un peu quand il faut
beaucoup et normalement non malm à
manger 3 vrai qu il faut des règles
atteignons 1 sur son rôle de point c'est
bon 24 heures est maintenant résolu fait
maintenant 20 circuits
je vais mettre ça dans ma marmite ça
c'est à dire la marinade lequel il a
mariné 24,4 aulas a ensuite je sors mon
foie gentiment oui y'en a pas dit c'est
ta joie de combien ça à peu près de 900
grammes à peu près 13 2 0 et voilà c'est
un très beau fois de canevas cuir là on
va le couvrir comme qui vous avez oublié
les leurs ce sera pour moi voilà et là
on va laisser cuire 30 minutes à peu
près 30 minutes pour un kilo de poids en
kilos de canard qui sont en famille puis
de toute façon et avec la jolie qui
mijote six heures avec le foie qui va me
jeter une heure on a bien temps de
s'occuper de leurs oignons du temps
quand la minute trente cinq minutes les
rognons les rognons de veau champagne 1
qu'allez vous faire je vais les émincés
un couteau qui court très très très très
regroupé un petit label il faut pas que
ce soit et p oui oui parce que c'est
quand même assez dur mais c'est très
vite cuillé musique qu'il faut pas le
faire cuire de lenteur jamais que sa
bouffonnerie les rognons que ça saute et
nous à bouillir et en dur ça y est vous
les mettez à la poêle seul et même à
poil et kesha 2 10 on essaie j'aurai le
doré un tout petit peu
car je te fais mal coupé tuer les saler
poivrer toujours été installé trois
vraiment la seule avec elle besoin de
plus si vous voulez l'avait d'accord
qu'il ya peu près mains comme s'il faut
pas que sa cuisse de la cje ustke vie
d'un côté de l'autre côté et vous salle
est relativement modérée manger vue et
dans l' il faudra vous causerez voilà
juste réseau la lie change de couleur
immédiatement ses formes
bon alors je vous donne un plat bien
joué mais pas les ventes ont frappé
d'entrée
là je vais les sortir chaska privant
fille livre dessus de vache et dix
secondes un petit peu de boue un petit
peu dit un petit peu fluide et nous les
mettons sous le nom très bien je les y
mettre tout ce qu'il te ment dans notre
bon vieux louise quoi juste à te dire
aux choses soit vous avez gardé le jus
de cuisson et apprendre une raison voilà
je vais mettre là-dedans des échalotes
oui voilà on va mettre ses juges à
l'autre mais bien dire il faut pas
qu'elle prenne couleur non elle vous
mènera combattants les champignons dont
il sait que l'opinion de paris en
lamelles prix cassé le cul rossi s'est
pourtant les familles je sais tout seul
on voyait de nouveau en pré salé pas
vrai ou pas du tout ce oui mais bien sûr
ça ça laissera gonf rires oui quelques
feuilles d'estragon frais que je couds
peut se mélanger aux sons modo celle qui
n'aime pas il peut le sortir
voilà saler poivrer parce ça c'est cette
farce est là et ensuite mais voilà alors
maintenant à un moment critique on va
mettre entre petits champagne on va les
arroser
ni de champagne et appréhender ce parc
lire tout doucement je vous donne bien
sûr voilà
c'est que ça réduit la valeur fois c'est
car même à couvert bien sûr donc je vous
donne notre jeu vient celle qui va
permettre de les voir au travers ou
prennent pour le magnifique
réfutant heure là et ça ça va être un
bon moment réduit donc la raison ce
serait que pendant ce temps nous voyons
nous en sommes avec le froid dans
l'autre petit fois il est posé oui il
est joli
il est resté à peu près une bonne
demi-heure de lui-même et maintenant à
mijoter à petit feu à frissonner dans ça
qu il faut le sortir sont abîmés voilà a
été il n'a pas trop fondu parce qu'un
fou d'aller souvent il faut terriblement
ça vient de quoi conduire trop vite il
faut qu'il soit frais un fois au
pakistan
alors maintenant on va mettre notre jury
on va préparer alors suis obligée de
prendre voilà la jolie que nous avons
fait honneur regardez comme elle est
jolie salle est superbe
bon allez vous dire qu'on a passé non
mais vous feriez vous pas que vous
espériez le fois là bas et vous leur
donnez bien parce que vous voulez vous
avez dit que vous vouliez milan voilà
alors là on va éviter de prendre le
graal recueilli un petit peu voilà on va
mettre un peu de bouillon la donne a
regardé comme un ancien jeu lesquels
seraient passés là qui est un petit peu
de jus de fois maïté pour être clair il
faut dire que on a dit tout à l'heure
que la gelée il fallait la cure 6 heures
oui on s'est bien entendu qu'on en avait
préparé la veille
mais oui mais ça il faut valeurs dirigé
non pas du savoir et à habas quand même
vous fait qu on prenne fin du 2e les et
puis c'est tout ils y croient qu en dix
minutes on a fait une jambe après 6
heures ils vont dire que racontent des
sentiments là et maintenant on couvre ce
choix de jeu les éléments c'est un gros
dur mais elle va le devenir
voilà le plus simplement du monde
ce qu'il faut voir son planning temps
avant pour bien savoir la ferme à série
un peu 24 heures ça six heures de
cuisson pour il a gelé ses sacs lille on
est devant un petit peu de têtes comme
un bruit
alors maintenant combien de temps donc
cette fois pris 24 heures il faut
jusqu'à demain j'irai demain jusqu'à
demain voilà pour le fait à midi et vous
le sortez l'un d'eux mêmes pour l'un des
milices est parfait alors ya encore un
petit quelque chose à faire avec les
rognons bon alors là la sauce a bien
réduit de moitié là on peut tous les
lieux il était mineur n'est pas fini
qu'est ce qu'il lui faudrait bien si
c'est la moutarde
oui on va y mettre du champagne est
dedans ça s'appelle de la moutarde au
charme a encore du champagne on va nous
dire qu'on fait trop de luxe
métaboliques et la grande bretagne ne va
pas la tête
alcoolique on est là pour faire le mieux
possible à la maison et on peut faire
plus simple
toujours pareil là et nous on fait mon
meilleur temps je vais pas m touré ne
soyez pas affolé par là quand même je
commençais à un qui prend non non non
non non non voilà je pense à la c rie
3-3 cuillerée prix en tous lieux oui on
peut faire bien le mélange et jettent ou
non du riz mettre la crème fraîche vers
bon on est bien sur mes photos je suis
un petit coup le style man inside
même s'ils arrivent à la cuillère est
différent beaucoup à la reine fraîche
par le jeu est pratiquement finie il ne
reste plus que les rognons il m car les
rognons les a tenus au chaud fou dans le
faux juste choisie par les attrape
nombreux à les prendre
oui ils sont devant vous vous êtes
devant la porte du four l'art là ça ça
va très bien très bien
voilà mes oignons valablement il va pas
les cuit comme nous ajuster suivait un
échange intense pour qu'ils prennent le
goût et c'est terminé
il nous reste plus qu'à présenter le
plat il souhaiter bon appétit à ceux qui
ont envie d'en faire les êtres humains
et bien vite vite on va présenter les
classes vont aimer ça y est notre foi et
son idée réfrigérateur où il a passé
plusieurs heures comme m oui 24 heures
au moins du jour au lendemain
c'est ça pour que la jeunesse soit bien
prise soit bien prise alors cette jolie
elle est pas si mal fait partie
maintenant et les troubles on voit que
les jolystes a été cette maison c'est
une riche famille est un média très bien
et le foie l'âge et le jour inquiète
il est écrit mais le moment où ils
ouvrent tout langois non
pourquoi et bien qu'il a c'est cuit tu
es jolie on va couper une belle escalope
à la lah abeilles les super regardez
comme il est beau il est magnifique on
peut pas essayer de les cueillir de
l'égayer un tout petit peu c'est à dire
que vous allez mettre un petit peu de
gelée au tour voilà évidemment ici c'est
chaud est bon chez vous lors un peu plus
dur allez olalalala une branche
d'estragon pour des durées faire joli et
mais bon appétit et regardez comme c'est
beau et ben si ces jeunes là voilà et
bien voilà un bon repas de fête
un beau repas de noël parce qu'il ya
aussi nous rognons qui sont bien dosées
alliant qui ne les oublierons arrêts ont
été fascinés par le froid ont commencé
par saïfi viser là vous vous rayonnez
hébert essayer d'en faire autant et vous
serez heureux parce que c'est bon et
halliche aux attentes
[Musique]